>> DUDE, YOU'RE GOING TO LOVE
THIS GAME.
ARE THE GRAPHICS AS INSANE AS
EVERYBODY SAYS THEY ARE?
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
"EARTH WAR 3."
IT MAKES "EARTH WAR 2" LOOK LIKE
A MARIO GAME.
AND IN V.R., FORGET ABOUT IT.
>> DOPE.
LET'S SMOKE SOME ZOMBIES.
>> YO, IT'S LIKE I'M ACTUALLY
THERE.
>> RIGHT?
>> HEY, YOU MUST BE THE NEW
SPECIAL DIVISIONS AGENT.
I'M DAMIEN.
I RUN THE SAFE HOUSE WHERE YOU
CAN UPGRADE GEAR AND CHECK
PROGRESS.
BUT FIRST, FIND THE WEAPONS
ROOM.
>> OH, WOW.
ALL RIGHT.
I'M GOING TO GET THE BIGGEST GUN
THEY HAVE.
>> DO IT, DUDE.
>> HEY, AGENT.
I'M ETHAN.
I RUN THE SAFE HOUSE WITH
DAMIEN.
THIS IS YOUR MISSION HUB.
OR IT WILL BE ONCE I GET IT UP
AND RUNNING.
>> ALL RIGHT.
UH, COOL.
NOT HERE TO TALK.
WHERE ARE THE GUNS AT?
>> HEY.
IT'S ME, DAMIEN.
I SAW YOU TALKING TO ETHAN.
I HEARD HIM SAY WE RUN THE SAFE
HOUSE TOGETHER.
WE DON'T.
I RUN IT.
HE HELPS.
>> ALL RIGHT.
>> ETHAN'S NICE
BUT HIS IDEAS AREN'T GREAT.
LIKE HIS MISSION HUB.
>> I JUST WANT TO SHOOT ZOMBIES
AND STUFF BUT THESE HELPER GUYS
KEEP, LIKE, BENDING MY EAR.
>> THE NPCs?
IF YOU DON'T WANT TO TALK TO
THEM, JUST HIT "B," DUDE.
>> HEY, I HEARD SOMETHING WEIRD
ABOUT ETHAN.
>> SKIP.
>> I GET IT.
YOU'RE A BUSY MAN.
NOW GO KICK SOME ASS.
>> AGENTS, THERE'S A ZOMBIE
HORDE IN SECTOR 3.
COME WITH ME TO GEAR UP.
>> FINALLY.
THANK YOU.
>> HEY.
I LIED ABOUT THE WHOLE ZOMBIE
HORDE THING SO WE CAN TALK
ALONE.
>> NO!
>> IS DAMIEN, LIKE, MAD AT ME?
>> I THINK HE'S JEALOUS OF THE
MISSION HUB BECAUSE IT WAS MY
IDEA.
OR IT'S SOMETHING ELSE.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
>> SHUT UP.
>> OH, I UNDERSTAND.
YOU DON'T HAVE TIME TO TALK.
BUT LET ME GUESS.
YOU HAVE TIME TO TALK TO DAMIEN.
THIS PLACE IS SO TOXIC.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> OH, MY GOD.
WHAT WASN'T ALL THAT ABOUT?
>> CAN I KILL THESE GUYS?
>> WATCH IT.
OUCH.
BE CAREFUL.
WATCH IT.
>> SKIP.
>> I GET IT, YOU'RE A BUSY MAN.
GO KICK SOME ASS.
>> GUNS, NOW, PLEASE!
>> AGENT.
THERE YOU ARE.
I'M KNOX, SECTION COMMANDER.
I'LL CUT TO THE CHASE.
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH ETHAN AND
DAMIEN?
GET REAL WITH THE BITCH.
>> NO!
>> WE'LL TALK LATER.
ANYWAY, THE WEAPONS STORAGE ROOM
IS THAT WAY.
GOOD LUCK.
>> OH, MY GOD.
FINALLY.
>> HEY, AGENT.
DAMIEN AND I ARE HASHING SOME
STUFF OUT.
>> NO!
>> YEAH, WE'RE GOING TO NEED A
MINUTE.
ALONE.
>> STORAGE ROOM LOCKED.
>> ARE YOU KIDDING ME?
>> ANY IDEA THAT'S NOT YOURS.
I MEAN, EVERY TIME NOW.
ETHAN, FOR GOD'S SAKE.
>> SCREW IT, I'M GOING OUT
WITHOUT A GUN.
>> LAB DOOR OPEN.
>> WHAT'S THE DEAL WITH ETHAN
AND DAMIEN?
>> NO!
>> GAME OVER.